hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter five of utilitarianism John
Stuart Mill is going to talk about
justice and its relationship with the
the key idea running throughout the the
integra treatise that of utility which
has to do with maximizing the positive
outcomes and minimizing the negative
outcomes for everybody in the community
concern and the question is whether the
notions of justice can map on to those
of utility so Mill says well if we want
to see whether this is possible first we
have to clarify for ourselves well what
is justice and conversely what is
injustice what do people actually mean
when they are using these terms and now
notice that we've got five things on the
board that's because Mill talks about
five or perhaps if you want to number
them a little bit differently perhaps
six things the the one that we might say
is sick this actually says annexed to
you know connected with the fifth one
and each of these is a somewhat
different conception you notice that
there are some similarities right legal
rights and and moral rights you know
respecting or honoring those but there's
actually some differences here and
there's the possibility of each and
every one of these coming into conflict
in one way or another with one of these
other conceptions when we get down to
particular cases this is why we grapple
with what we feel to be moral dilemmas
and this is also why we find competing
conceptions of justice you might say
going to war with each other in the body
politic or in the court of public
opinion so what are these five notions
or five conceptions of justice that mill
says most people tend to have one is
respecting legal rights
another is respecting a different kind
of right a moral right and then there's
giving people what they
deserve keeping promises or meeting
expectations and then finally being
impartial and maintaining equality of
some sort between persons and he gives
us a brief discussion of each of these
in turn
allowing us to see what he's actually
talking about so we want to look at what
he actually says he says it's considered
unjust to deprive anyone of certain
things his personal liberty that is his
freedom his property or any other thing
which belongs to him by law so if you
know there's a lot of things that fall
on your property house you know a car
for a lot of us you know our money well
however we happen to have a you know
money in my wallet as cash or a credit
card or something in my bank account all
of those things are our property there's
other things that we might talk about as
rights that we have that that are
legally recognized right to privacy for
example right one that took a lot of
hashing out over the years at least here
in the United States with our Supreme
Court figure well what do you get what
exactly counts us as privacy a very
important issue right now when we think
about well who owns our data who owns
our intellectual property for example
what I'm shooting right here in a
certain sense belongs to me
but I'm posting it on YouTube which is
where you're watching it and YouTube is
going to use it and make money on it by
putting ads and all sorts of things even
if I disable my ads they're going to
have ads running on the side and all
those sorts of things well all of that
has to do with legal rights
so mill goes on and he says one instance
of the application of terms of just and
unjust is a perfectly definite sense it
is just to respect unjust to violate the
legal rights of anyone and of course he
says there's going to be a
options to this but this is one common
conception of justice
you know you punched me in the face
well you violated my legal rights you
called me a terrible name you might not
have violated my legal rights you said a
terrible name and that terrible name was
something slanderous or libelous okay
now you violated my legal rights and we
can go on and on the second one is very
very interesting because legal rights
for as far as mill is concerned don't
exhaust the possibilities of right and
wrong this is something that we always
have to keep in mind there can be unjust
laws there can be laws that give one
person the right legally to do something
to another person which that person
shouldn't have the right to do in that
case we talk about a moral right so for
example it used to be the case here in
the United States as well as in many
other places that women were not allowed
to own property on the one hand and in
many cases were actually treated as if
they were property of you know
particular men mill mill was a great
opponent of that sort of thing and a
proponent of women's equality
mill would say that's clearly a
violation of a moral right even if say
that that man husband father has a legal
right to do so
another great example yet here in the
United States it used to be legal for
people of one race to own people of
another race and you know the Supreme
Court actually affirmed that you know in
for example the Dred Scott decision
which later on was overturned as being
bad law but it was for awhile the law of
the land and we would say that it was
granting a legal right where there was
no moral right so Mill will talk about
this in saying that legal rights of
which a person is deprived may be rights
which ought not to have belonged to him
in the first place in the law which
gives that person the
rights may be a bad law allowing
somebody to be a slave of another person
that's a bad law
so mill says in this case we the law is
not the ultimate criterion of justice
but may give to one person a benefit or
impose on another and evil which justice
condemns and then we we talk not in
terms of legal right but he says moral
right so we say a second case of
injustice consists in taking or
withholding from any person that to
which they have a moral right that's a
very important conception of justice the
third he says is very very basic this is
something that when people are put on
the spot and they asked what is justice
and that's a difficult question
they often will respond with some
variation on this saying well it's when
you give people what they deserve and
mill says this doesn't just include
giving people nice things goods it also
includes giving people bad things so if
somebody violates the laws violates
people's rights maybe they deserve to be
punished in that case you're imposing
something bad upon them and that is part
of our conception of justice this can be
done by the way I in in modes that are
not simply retributive but actually look
for some other kind of benefit to accrue
from it the utilitarians were actually
big proponents of punishment that would
look to the future and have some sort of
positive effect for society they weren't
the only ones by the way Thomas Hobbes
talks about that as well in his laws of
nature who they were getting a little
bit far afield but in any case he says
it's universally considered just each
person should obtain that whether good
or evil which he deserves and unjust
that he should obtain a good or be made
to undergo an evil which he does not
deserve so that's the flip side of it if
I deserve to you know suffer a
penalty because I don't like to pay my
taxes or I like to play my music so loud
that everybody in my building is stuck
listening to it or you know pick any
other sort of thing that you want I'm
stealing people's packages from the
front doors which does happen quite a
bit as I find out on Facebook in certain
neighborhood groups I deserve to suffer
something I don't deserve to get away
with it right my neighbors don't deserve
to have to listen to my music at 3:00 in
the morning blaring very loudly
something is out of whack and there
needs to be some sort of redress so that
that's another very important
understanding of justice then we get to
a very interesting one which is also in
a different way at the core of justice
and that is keeping faith keeping
promises meeting certain expectations
mill will will say says it's confessedly
unjust to break faith with anyone to
violate an engagement either express or
implied to disappoint expectations
raised by our conduct at least and
here's the key provision if we have
raised those expectations knowingly and
voluntarily great example of this
happens in relationships all the time
you know when we one person accuses the
other in a dating situation of leading
them on right there are there are
certain things that I suppose could be
taken as you know sort of express
consent I am going to sleep with you
tonight say that to another person
they've got a pretty good expectation
that unless you're a crowd you know
pathological liar you're intending to
sleep with them of course you know that
consent could be revoked or whatever is
going on but there's something there
wearing something revealing being flirty
talking to one person instead of talking
to another person in most people's books
most reasonable people's books that does
not count as
raising expectations knowingly and
voluntarily you know they may it may be
viewed as such by the person who then
gets upset about it and makes a big
stink about it you know rights and
social media complaints to the person
tries to take matters into their own
hands but they would be unjust in that
case we can only expect of people what
it is reasonable to expect of them but
if people do make promises if I tell you
that if you join in this this contest
you know there's going to be a prize
somebody better get a prize right
because that's that's an agreement that
we're making right there if you hire me
to tutor you and during the tutorial
session I just talk about you know my
favorite heavy metal bands unless you
were hiring me to talk about the history
of heavy metal I'm letting you down I am
committing injustice in a certain
respect and for me to follow through on
the agreement that I make that is
another form of justice likewise if I
provide you a service you should pay me
for that service if we've agreed upon a
price if you if you walk up to the front
of the store and you put something on
the counter and it's got a price tag on
it presumably you have agreed to pay
that price unless it's the kind of
situation where you get to haggle the
fifth type of justice and injustice that
he talks about he has to do with
partiality this is very interesting
so mill says it's by universal universal
admission inconsistent with justice to
be partial what is what does being
partial means it means favoring one
person over another because of some you
know factor that is not relevant to the
case at hand so a great example of
partiality is when we favor those who
come from our own group whether that be
you know in terms of location you know i
favor somebody who has the same kind of
accent as me or the same color skin or
you know is a man or is 47 years old at
this point in time or pick whatever you
like by the way it's also a lack of
partiality to swing to the other extreme
and to say well I'm gonna make up for
past abuses I'm going to fade as a man
I'm gonna favor women or I will favor
young people or old people because I'm
middle-aged right or pick whatever you
like that would be partiality as well
another great example of partiality is
when we talk about corruption people pay
extra money and they get better services
than everybody else
bribery is an example of that right this
is raises all sorts of complaints and
Mill says that this is very closely
connected with our notion of equality
relevant equality as being a part of
justice this doesn't mean that justice
equals equality and not every form of
equality is necessarily just you know a
great example of this do we pay
everybody the same wage perhaps there
are some jobs that ought to be more
remunerative
because there are more onerous or they
require greater skills or they perhaps
even we might say they are in demand and
so the people who can provide them ought
to get a premium because of that and
other people who are doing something
that anybody can do and is easy to do
perhaps don't get quite as much there
there it's not showing impartiality or
you know inequality for its own sake
it's a kind of inequality that could in
fact have some sort of rational basis so
he says nearly allied to this idea of
impartiality is that of equality which
often enters as a component part both
into the conception of justice and into
the practice and in the eyes of many
persons constitutes its essence now all
of these notice could come into conflict
with each other in one way or another
we already saw that respecting moral
rights really only becomes an issue when
the legal system is in some way screwed
up so there's already a connection
between those giving people what they
deserve could that ever come into
conflict say with respecting legal
rights it depends on how the laws are
actually framed there may be some cases
to where to enact what is morally right
might in fact mean that some people get
less or more good or bad than they
deserve
what about making promises can you make
promises that turn out that later on be
a bad idea where you say well if I
fulfilled my promise other people's
rights are going to become affected in
bad ways or I won't be able to give
people what they genuinely deserve
should you break the promise that in
that case or should you stick with the
promise and say well unfortunately this
other part is going to have to give in
being impartial treating everybody in
that in relevant ways equally can that
come into conflict with these yes there
are certain legal rights that may often
come into conflict with it there may in
fact be some cases where moral rights
say that we shouldn't treat everybody
equally or where we've made a promise
that is going to require that we don't
behave in the same way towards towards
everybody precisely because we made a
promise so the question then is how do
we reconcile these and to answer that
mill is going to make recourse to what
he calls utility
you